hello everybody my name is joseph
zachary i'm associate professor of
medicine at the university of iowa and
uh it's my pleasure to be here to talk
to you about
uh
the the rule of ideal or orientation
oxygenase
dioxygenase in
in cancers and the title of my talk is
ideal in melanoma deserves a few other
further evaluation
here are my disclosures
ido or endolamine 2 3-dioxygenase
is an enzyme that converts essential
amino acid tryptophan to kinem
which results in tryptophan depletion
and kinetic accumulation
and the outcome of this
phenotype is immune suppression
to the tumor microenvironment
and the tubers hijack the ido
pathway
to facilitate immune response their
immune escape
ido has been associated with uh worse
prognosis in multiple
tumor types including melanoma non-small
cell uh lung cancer
and multiple other
tumors
listed here
and multiple ideo inhibitors
do exist
currently in different clinical trials
majority of them are
direct enzymatic inhibitors like
epicadostat napoxy mod or
linorodostat
as opposed to indoximod which is the
agent
where you we use in our clinical trial
uh works at
different levels including
uh
at the
different immune cells uh including the
pause pause i would like to
record pre-record
no problem just go back to where you're
ready to present and then take about a
three second pause
i go from the beginning because i was
distracted by a phone call uh sure yeah
that's fine
no problem just make sure you go all the
way back um with your slides
to the first page and then it may say
push to audience once you get there
okay
okay perfect all right so just take
another pause and then you can begin
okay
hello my name is
jose zakaria i'm associate professor of
medicine at the university of iowa and
medical oncologist at the holden
comprehensive cancer center it's my
pleasure to talk to you about
ido pathway in
melanoma or in dolamine two three
dioxygenase
and the title of my talk is ideal and
melanoma deserves further evaluation
these are my disclosures
idol or indolamine 2 3 dioxygenase is an
enzyme that converts essential amino
acid tryptophan to can urinate and
results in depletion of tryptophan and
uh accumulation of conurinene and the
outcome of this pathway basically is a
suppressive phenotype to the
uh
tumor
micro immune microenvironments
the tumors do hijack the igo pathway to
facilitate
immune escape
ido is overexpressed in multiple types
of tumors as listed here uh including
melanoma cell lung cancer and multiple
others
and its higher expression is associated
uh with
uh poor prognosis as illustrated here in
this
kaplan-meier curve
there are multiple
ido inhibitors that
exist in different stages of clinical
trial majority of them are direct
enzymatic inhibitors
uh like apocadostat and oxmod or
in rhodostat as opposed to in doxmode
which is a drug we studied in our
clinical trial acts directly on the
immune cells
to reverse
ideal pathway-mediated suppression
studies have suggested that indoximod
enables the effector t cells in tumors
and attenuates
in in draining lymph nodes
and and results in differentiation of
the regulatory
t cells more towards
helper
t cells phenotype
multiple pre-clinical data suggest the
synergistic effect between nox mod and
other
uh
checkpoint inhibitor including pg-1 and
ctla-4
and
these pre-clinical data have set up the
stage for our clinical trial
that
we presented previously and about to
publish in a journal of
immunotherapy in cancer
this was a phase two clinical trial
combining indoximond plus checkpoint
inhibitor in advanced melanoma it was a
single arm
open label study with a primary endpoint
of objective response rates
the main eligibility criteria listed
here including unresectable uh or
advanced melanoma uh treatment naive for
immuno
for immunotherapy the prior
beeras
inhibitors or radiation therapy where
we're allowed
uh we basically used doxmode at 1200
milligram
twice daily
uh along with the standard of care and
checkpoint inhibitor and we continued
treatment until toxicity or disease
progression
the trial allowed
at the time when we had we started the
trial uh
admin volume and diploma all of them
were
appropriate first line treatment for
metastatic melanoma so the design as
listed here shows uh that
it was a provider or or investigator
choice of uh pembroids map
or epileum along with an oxmod until
disease progression and
we allowed at that point to switch the
pd-1 inhibitor to ctla4 or vice versa as
illustrated here
we have treated 131 or screen 131
patients on this clinical trial and the
safety
uh
population uh
included 114
patients
of those
those were
mainly treated with pembroidsmith and
indox
per provider
choice
and that is the data we are presenting
here of those 114 patients treated with
pembro and
indoximond 18 patients had ocular
melanoma and we are excluding them from
our efficacy cohorts given the
different biology compared to
uh other non-ocular melanoma
we did have seven uh patients who pro
who came off study
prior to the first uh
uh on treatment imaging
due to adverse events or uh withdrawal
of consent and that left us with 89
patients uh
uh
who are non-ocular melanoma treated with
femoralism and oxymoron and we call them
our efficacy cohorts
of those 89 patients these are the
baseline characteristics median age of
61 which is
expected in
in
general melanoma population and majority
of them were male caucasian
uh almost 90 percent of them had stage
four disease uh about 10 of them 10
patients had unresectable stage
3 b and c
a quarter of them had had
elevated ldh
and uh 14 patients did receive uh prior
radiation and 16 patients did receive
prior systemic therapy including
uh reed or bilas and mac inhibitor or
previous remote history of interferon uh
or il-2 but none of them received
checkpoint inhibitors
this is our efficacy data in the uh
intention to treat population of all
patients with treated with them uh
non-ocular melanoma treated with
uh pembrolizumab and detoximont we had
96 patients and we had an overall
response rate of 47
percent with a complete remission of 19
and uh disease control rate of 65
percent in our um
evaluable or efficacy population
of 89 patients who received
on treatment
images
we did have uh 51 percent was over
response rate and 20 complete response
uh and a disease control rate of uh 70
we did have a medium pfs of about 12.4
months
and
of interest we observed in the 14
patients who received prior radiation
therapy
we observed 9 out of the 14
achieving an overall response rate of
64 percent and disease control rate of
86
speaking to the potential synergistic
effect between the radiation
and and immunotherapy granted this is a
small sample of patients and it is
worth studying
it further in larger uh population
in looking at the pdl1
staining
we had
30 patients out of 56
where or or we had a pdl1
status known for 56 patients of those 30
patients or 54 percent had pdl one
positive and 26 patients or 46 percent
had a pt and one negative
and the overall response rate in the pdl
one positive was about 70 percent and
then the pdl one negative was uh 46
this spider plot shows
type of responses as you can observe
majority of responses happened within
the first three months on treatment
a few responses happened six months and
beyond and as one would expect these
responses are durable
as you can see from this swimmer plot we
do have many patients who went on
treatment uh beyond two years
and this uh
waterfall plot uh does show the
different type of responses we had uh
with the green showing the complete uh
remission and the blue showing the
partial remission if not we do have uh
some patients who achieve deep
partial response and we continue to
watch them on a clinical trial
the side effects profile of this
combination
is is
not outside the expectation of one
of what one would expect with any single
agent pd1 inhibitor in other words
as you can see here the side effects are
to be expected with immunotherapy
including fatigue in some 62 percent of
patients and skin rash in 40 percent and
itching of in 35 percent i wanted to
point out we encountered minimal grade 3
and for toxicity here as listed uh in
this table and we did not encounter any
treatment related deaths
uh
utilizing a pre and on treatment biopsy
in 14
patients in our cohort as listed here uh
in red color showed the responders and
the uh
in the green color is the non-responder
uh testing for ido positivity by immuno
fluorescence we have observed that the
responders did
achieve down regulation of their uh ido
expression as opposed to the
non-responders uh granted this is a
smaller
sample and it is worth uh studying in in
future uh trials
and breaking down uh these responses uh
or this uh stain according to the ki 67
positive as one would expect in uh in
tumor cells and negative in stromal or
immune cells we can see that majority of
these uh
down regulation of ido is accounted uh
uh for for the
uh stromal or the immune cells and we
did not encounter that igo down
expression uh in the uh tumor uh tumor
cells
and in looking at the kaplan-meier
curve here in the second panel
and
correlating the pfs with the ido
expression we have observed
a tendency uh towards improve uh pfs in
patients who had a high igo uh
expression as opposed to the lower uh
but again that is uh
not that was not sexually significant
and it is worth studying in in further
uh
uh or larger sample size uh we did not
encounter that correlation between pfs
and pdl1 uh in in the in this as
illustrated in this graph
we did rna-seq on this paired sample
in 14 patients
six of them had response and eight of
them
without response and as illustrated in
this volcano uh plot unsupervised
clustering showed a clear cluster
of inflammatory genes upregulated by
treatment
uh primarily in the responders and these
genes basically related to either
activated t-cells natural killers
or
antigen presenting cells
as opposed we observe down regulation
in genes related to
melanoma like uh mac and and cake
genes and we did not observe that that
phenomenon in the non-responders
as illustrated in this second
figure
other preclinical or other uh early
phase clinical trials uh using other uh
radio inhibitors with apocados that and
pembrokesome in echo 202
did show similar uh encouraging results
in 54 patients where we were
we observed 56 percent an overall
response rate and 15 complete response
and a medium pfs of 12.4 months however
unfortunately in
in a larger phase a free trial comparing
uh pembrolisma uh plus apache stats
versus uh pembro uh and placebo uh we
did not encounter uh superiority of a
pakistan arm compared to the placebo
as illustrated uh in this uh kaplan uh
meyer curve uh the overall surprise
survival was identical between
the uh femoralisumab and the piccatus
that harm uh compared to uh pembro and
placebo and unfortunately this puts a
negative
uh impact on the ito uh uh pathway
uh there are some uh theories why uh
this clinical trial uh was uh negative
uh there is some uncertainty regarding
or surrounding the doors of pakistan
that was used uh in this clinical trial
with 100
milligrams
whether that was
really the the
right dose to test and in looking into
the
pharmaco
kinetics uh data as you can see here uh
the the
suppression of kenyan uh
really happens at higher uh doses uh
at 600
milligram of pacquiao
and beyond looking at this uh figure
four pooled analysis of multiple epec
understand and checkpoint inhibitor
trials you we can see i'm sorry it's a
little bit uh blurry uh curve but you
can see the suppression of kenyan is
really happening at high doses at 600
milligrams nevertheless we have learned
significant
uh
lessons from uh this fp3 clinical trial
whether uh
uh despite the the negative outcome
unfortunately um
[Music]
i guess the very most important uh
or the most important lesson is uh
should we have a randomized phase two
studies prior to jumping onto randomized
uh phase phase three trials take it like
a stepwise
approach
before jumping all the way from
a phase one uh to a randomized phase
phase three
nevertheless uh the the ido
pathway is
uh coming back uh now again with uh
multiple uh clinical trials including uh
different types of malignancies uh
there is ongoing clinical trial
currently in uh bladder cancer uh using
uh
ido inhibitor uh khk2455
uh in combination uh with avelo map in
uh platinum uh in in bladder cancer
patients uh after progression of
uh cis-platinum-based chemotherapy or
uh
if if they have
if they are platinum ineligible and
there is an ongoing clinical trial uh in
neoadjuvant setting
in bladder cancer
utilizing uh ideoinhibitor
in combination with
chemotherapy
as illustrated in in this
schema
so
i i guess
the main message here is we do have a
long uh
long history of ido
uh in
inhibition and the benefit in the
pre-clinical model and we do have
multiple
early stage clinical trials that do
suggest
uh
the activity of
this pathway or the importance of this
pathway in cancer and the the activity
or the the importance of targeting this
pathway
in cancer and our
results in 89 patients do seem
encouraging to be studied further in
larger
randomized clinical trial and we hope to
see
this bladder studies
showing activity
in the future with that i would like to
thank you for this